the mit center for advanced virtuality
you could look at it as a way to
investigate how we can blend the
imagination with the physical world
a lot of our work involves simulating
social phenomena such as discrimination
in the workplace bias within the
classrooms how we see each other in
different circumstances depending on our
background ways that we are
categorized how can we use these
simulations to spark the imagination to
spark perspective transformation
we've done work on issues of everyday
discrimination sometimes called
microaggression using video gaming as a
platform for addressing this kind of
issue
our work also addresses issues like
personalization sometimes people might
have a sense of needing to be pushed in
a certain kind of area to be challenged
sometimes people need to be scaffolded
and supported and to have technologies
that can do
either as needed i think is a kind of
crucial advance
[Music]
the future of rich educational
experience is interactive communications
in a post-pandemic world where
remoteness is ever more important and
where the technologies to support that
are multiplying this center on a
integrated basis
can with students and faculty and and
tapping all corners of mit
be a
critically important
significant contributor to that thinking
we are gratified to receive an emmy
award for interactive documentary
this particular work is called an event
of moon disaster and it's a project that
constructs a deep fake of richard nixon
giving the speech that he would have
given if the moon landing had been
unsuccessful faith has ordained
that the men who went to the moon to
explore in peace
it's actually a beautiful and elegant
speech but it was never given it's
computer generated using machine
learning techniques to explore in peace
we'll stay on the moon this is a project
which helps people to understand
how do we recognize this kind of
technology can we recognize this kind of
technology
it's really a form of learning that you
could say responds to the particular
culture not just of the subject matter
but of the user of the system as well
and i think that's just a hallmark of a
kind of broader approach in learning in
which we can personalize and customize
experiences
there is not just one truth and by
seeing the same story through different
lenses that broader message can emerge
helping to build this studio and lab
that uses simulation and technologies of
virtuality for the social good and
inventing new forms of learning that's
engaging and immersive i would say that
that's the key towards pushing our
agenda forward
you